hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen in today's what i in a
day youtuber review
we will be looking at lifestyle youtuber
tiffany ma from the channels
miss tiffany ma and tiffany ma so
tiffany is a spitfire ball of energy who
lives in la
and post a wide range of content from
organizational and cleaning videos
diys room makeovers etc but before we
start a few disclaimers
the information in this video is for
entertainment and educational purposes
only so you should always speak to a
healthcare provider about your unique
healthcare needs
number two the recommendations for each
individual meal that i review
is designed to give you a variety of
ideas on how to optimize meals for
balance
variety and satiety whether or not one
individual meal or even one day
is balanced or healthy does not matter
in the grand scheme of one's health
especially if a person is eating in
response to their physical
and emotional needs i give these
suggestions as examples and inspiration
for you
but you can also gather this data for
yourself
over time simply by listening to your
own body number three
i am filming this well in advance and
obviously cannot capture an
entire catalog of a youtuber's diet so
keep in mind that this may not
accurately
represent what they currently eat for
please be kind in the comments both here
and on tiffany's channel
number five a trigger warning that some
graphics and some discussions
may be disturbing to some of my viewers
so
feel free to skip this video if you feel
that that may be triggering for you
and finally do not forget to subscribe
to this channel and ring that little
bell so you never
miss out on a video okay
so in this first video i'm about to look
at
tiffany discloses that she went
vegetarian a few months ago
and naturally lost six pounds in the
process
but because she wasn't trying to lose
that weight she says that it must mean
that her body was just settling at its
natural set point
now first of all that may be true nobody
can deny
tiffany's natural weight and of course
bodies do
naturally come in larger and smaller
sizes
some of you might say that tiffany's bmi
is considered underweight at
95 pounds and 5-2 the reality is that
bmi is incredibly faulty and while we do
have research to suggest that there are
greater health risks associated with
being in the
underweight category than the overweight
or even in some cases the obese category
we would never exclusively look at bmi
to judge if someone is at their
healthiest
happiest weight rather it really comes
down to their behavior
how they feel and their thought process
around food
so if you are wondering where your set
point lies some signs that you are
likely
not at your set point include you have
strict
rules or rituals around food that
dictate when you can eat
and what you can eat outside of just
listening to your body's cues
your weight fluctuates frequently and
significantly
based on changes to your routine you
feel preoccupied with food
and feel guilty for eating something
that you feel is
bad and you have symptoms like low
libido fatigue
coldness low energy irritability
menstrual irregularity or extreme hunger
in contrast if your weight has been
relatively stable for your adult life
and you haven't engaged in a lot of
dieting behavior and you feel energetic
and in good health there's a good chance
you are
where your body wants to be now i will
say
that sometimes people do lose weight
unintentionally
when they go on a plant-based diet and
that doesn't
necessarily mean that that weight loss
is
necessarily healthy for them again it
might be in tiffany's case
i'm not saying that it's not but
depending on what she's eating
a lot of plant-based foods are just
naturally lower in calories
and higher in fiber so it can sometimes
become more difficult to meet your
caloric
and nutrient needs but i guess we will
see when we analyze
all of these days to figure out how this
applies specifically to tiffany
i also just want to mention that tiffany
did disclose that she suffered
from binge eating disorder and bulimia
in the past
but that she now has a healthier
relationship with food
and that unlike a lot of the content
that we see online on
youtube that what she is eating in these
days is fully authentic and real
now i definitely appreciate authenticity
so without further ado
let's meet tiffany so every single
morning
i fill up my glass of water i prefer
clear water bottles so i can see how
much i'm actually drinking
i probably drink about three or four of
these every single day
okay so i think this is actually a
really great tip
having a visual cue of your water in
front of you
is a great way to encourage yourself to
drink up
let's see what we get to eat i break my
intermittent fast
with candy if you guys don't know this
intermittent fasting
allows your body to go into a fasting
mode which will mean that your body
kind of eats away at its own fat
reserves because there's no food in your
actual stomach
but i naturally just didn't run fast i
normally stop eating at 9 pm every
single night
and around 12 to 1 p.m is when i start
eating my first bites of candy or meal
or whatever
okay so right out the gate tiffany
discusses how she's intermittent fasting
which sends a few mixed messages when
she just finished saying that she lost
six pounds going vegetarian
and not trying to lose weight if you
watch that whole clip
her description of intermittent fasting
didn't mention any of the potential
non-weight loss benefits like improving
blood sugar regulation
and improving heart health measures it
solely
is about losing weight and fat so
tiffany describes intermittent fasting
as your body eating its
fat reserves since there's no food left
in your stomach
and to that i would say yes and no
so intermittent fasting can help reduce
insulin levels
increase growth hormones and increase
the release of the fat
burning hormone norepinephrine all of
which may contribute to
weight loss also extending our natural
fast overnight
into the day may use up our glycogen
stores
which may cause a small increase in fat
oxidation
but it's not that your body is just
magically eating up all your fat
reserves because there's no food in your
stomach
and the truth is without a total caloric
deficit
we're still looking at a pretty
insignificant impact on weight loss
for that reason a lot of experts believe
that the main reason
people lose weight on an intermittent
fasting diet if they do
is not because of these magical
metabolic changes but because eating in
a smaller window
typically reduces how much food you eat
so if you're the type of person to break
your fast and go hog wild within your
eating window
then this probably won't be an effective
weight loss strategy
for you and i would say i probably have
three or four every single day this
morning i had two
and this one is gonna be number three
okay so
first of all it's always refreshing to
see a youtuber have a normal
relationship with candy
especially one who apparently has come
from an eating disorder background
i would say that in the youtube wellness
space there's an overwhelming emphasis
on avoiding refined sugars and candy and
other processed foods
consistently are showing up on the bad
list of foods so kudos to tiffany for
eating what she loves
even if it's not a conventionally
healthy choice
but of course if i put my dietitian hat
on
and you're asking me what a balanced
meal looks like
especially one to break a fast after
several hours
of being up with no food in your belly
candy alone
probably wouldn't be my first choice
obviously
you know me i like to see me some
balance and with just 100 calories and
nothing else
there's definitely room to add to this
meal
so i'm not about taking away the red
vines because clearly
tiffany loves her licorice but if we
were to add in some yogurt and
nuts or an egg on toast or some almond
butter with fruit
we would have a more substantial sized
breakfast
and we would have some fat protein and
or fiber
to help slow down that sugar rash habits
that i do that
probably has helped me lose weight so
one of the biggest things i do
is i eat really freaking slow
if you're just snacking on something
unhealthy try to cut down
your bites to half the bites you would
normally take
and then double the amount of times
you're chewing food so that way you're
eating four times slower than you
normally eat
so either your body will catch up to you
being like hey you're actually full why
are you still eating
or you'll just eat less food in general
normally my bites are like this
that is crazy that is a normal licorice
bite for me that is so little
and then i probably chew it hold on let
me naturally chew this and count how
many times i naturally chew before
swallowing
[Music]
that was 23 chews so again um
i'm kind of troubled by tiffany doling
out weight loss advice when she assured
us
and her audience that the weight loss
just kind of happened naturally without
her trying
and that was evidence of her new lower
weight
being her true healthy weight as for the
tip
tiffany suggests eating twice as slow
eating your food
in twice as many bites and then chewing
each bite
as much as you can to give your body
time to acknowledge
that you're full so in general eating
more slowly
is a great way to pick up on the sensual
pleasures
inherent in food when we shovel food in
on the go and eat mindlessly it's very
hard to pick up
on all of its flavors aromas and
textures
it also gives yourself time to check in
with your hunger and fullness cues
since it can take about 20 minutes for
your brain to register that you're full
this is actually a big part of mindful
eating and mindful eating is a big part
of intuitive eating
and if this strategy is working for
tiffany and what she naturally finds
enjoyable
great however i do just want to flag
that chewing a quarter inch piece of
licorice
23 times may be triggering for some
people
and may reinforce some of the common
restriction tips
that you'll see on a lot of pro anime
sites yes it's important to invest time
in eating and make
meal times a priority but it's also
important to be realistic
and acknowledge that we don't all have
an hour to eat a single piece of
licorice
it would take my entire day just to eat
my caloric needs at that rate
and i don't want people to watch that
clip and think that that level
of like food mincing is necessary in
order to hear your body's hunger cues
even if this is totally normal healthy
behavior to tiffany
like i said it only takes most bodies
about
20 minutes to hear those cues
let's take a look at lunch
put some on the outer edges and then i
throw the rest of them
right in the middle yum okay so this
looks like a tasty breakfast
we've got a good amount of carbs from
the instant oatmeal
blueberries and banana plus a little
protein and fat
from the peanut butter now considering
tiffany's first
meal of the day was completely devoid of
protein and fat
and this one is also still relatively
low only
10 grams of each i would say that she
could definitely add a bit
more protein maybe some protein powder
stirred in
or topping it with greek yogurt or some
hemp hearts flax
maybe more peanut butter or just pairing
it with an
egg or two on the side but let's take a
look at snack
go on some tahini yes
yum i am gonna grab another snack like i
want something like
really sweet and unhealthy and i kind of
want licorice or i kind of wanted these
cookies that i got from trader joe's
okay i only have one or two of these
left
i might as well eat the last two so
that's another 170 calories
so that's gonna be 870 calories total if
i finish both of these which i'm pretty
freaking sure i will officially
done she's nice and empty anytime eating
sweets i really savor it and i
probably took a good like six minutes
just to eat two little cookies
so that is probably all the snacks i
should let myself eat for now
okay so i have to say that i'm obsessed
with watermelon with tahin
and i actually have a recipe on my blog
and channel for watermelon sticks
with tahini because it is just so so
good
also cookie butter anything is one of
the greatest
pleasures in life so i totally get
tiffany's obsession
but again since we've only had a carb
only breakfast
and a carb heavy lunch if we're talking
balance i would have loved to see
a little bit more protein healthy fats
and also some fiber in this snack just
to balance things out
also we haven't seen any vegetables at
all today
so while i applaud tiffany's ability to
reject the clean eating
diet mentality i would still love to see
a little bit more balance
nutrition and variety so to me this is
not about cutting these foods out
i love watermelon it's super refreshing
and healthy
and i think two cookies is a totally
reasonable size snack
this isn't like an unhealthy cheat day
binge but we can give the snack a little
bit more staying power
by adding in maybe some yogurt with the
watermelon or some veggies and hummus
or some trail mix with nuts and seeds
but let's take a look at how things look
for dinner
i think she's ready she looks so
freaking good
okay so i just made my freaking
flatbread and i counted all my calories
and i'm gonna also add honey on top so
with honey and everything that i made if
i finished all of this it would be
600 calories oh my god i honestly want
to make it again for tomorrow
so it's currently 10 p.m i'm literally
so freaking full right now i think
that's all i'm gonna eat for the rest of
the night
i can't imagine stuffing myself with
anything else because i'm so freaking
full
okay this looks like an awesome dinner
we've got carbs from the non-flatbread
veggies with the onions and the zucchini
some protein in the ricotta
and some fat in the olive oil that she
used to cook in
i know tiffany's vegetarian but i think
we could still pump up the protein a
little bit here considering
we haven't had a whole lot all day so
maybe we could add some nutritional
yeast or seeds or crushed nuts
or add some more ricotta dollops on top
i also appreciate that tiffany ate as
much of her flatbread that she
comfortably could
and just like set it aside because she
felt full
awesome use of that intuition now before
we comment on the adequacy of
the diet let's take a look at day two
so in this next video tiffany does the
chloe ting's
two week shred challenge with some other
popular youtubers
and starts her day off with what looks
like a pretty
challenging workout
like kicked my butt i can't even breathe
oh my god
it is currently 3 p.m i actually haven't
ate yet i figured
i might throw up if i ate before and i
didn't want to throw up
because i haven't worked out this hard
in such a long time here's my first meal
of the day it is
a chia seed oatmeal with oat milk half a
banana
and about 20 blueberries this is hands
down one of my favorite meals ever and i
mix the oat milk with peanut butter and
it just makes everything
nice and thick okay so i have no idea
how this girl manages to do that workout
with no fuel in the tank
and then not eat anything until what she
says is 3 p.m
i am legit dying just thinking about
that scenario right now but
anyways we have pretty much the same
meal as
day 1 but with a little bit of chia
seeds
and this time we have 20 blueberries
instead of 15.
now i have to just say that it may be
triggering to some of you that she's
explicitly
counting out the blueberries but anyways
since this is a post-workout meal i
would say it's even
more important that we're getting that
protein in if we're talking about
optimizing for sports nutrition
we would probably want to see two to
three times the amount of protein that
she had
to get a solid post-workout ratio with
the carbs
this will ensure our muscle fibers have
a chance to rebuild
after being torn during activity and
that is what allows muscles to grow
and you to feel your best after working
out but let's see what she has
next a freaking
barbecue we have going on we got some
mushrooms and onions
corn zucchinis yum holy freaking a cat
okay so this looks like an amazingly
well balanced meal
we've got carbs from the burger bun and
corn some protein and fat in the veggie
burger
plus some extra fat in the cooking oil
that she used
plus some fiber-rich veggies from the
onion mushroom
zucchini and corn love a good
summer grilled meal and this looks super
delish and also
really really easy as well now i have to
say
i would definitely want to see some
snacks or at least a bigger
breakfast lunch meal since she didn't
even have her first bite
until 3 p.m but let's take a look at
another day
in this kind of two week challenge she's
doing
really hungry though so i think i'm just
going to eat a piece of bread
why is this bread not tasty
oh man that bread is totally my style
but to me i just feel like it's begging
for a little spread on top of some sort
but now carbs are definitely the
preferred fuel before a cardio heavy
workout
especially if you're eating close to
working out but if tiffany is worried
about having like a heavy meal dragging
her down pre-workout
she could totally opt for a lower fat
spread like some fruits
preserves or like a little mashed banana
spread on top with a little flax seed on
there
but anyways let's see what she has for
her post-workout meal
so we have ourselves a super late lunch
that is so good
holy crap
[Music]
okay so same same but kind of different
um this oatmeal bowl is made with
macadamia nut milk instead of oat milk
and she didn't
mention that this one had nut butter in
it but it very well
might as well um and since we've only
had bread for breakfast
and now we're having a straight up carb
meal we would again want to boost up the
protein for muscle growth
and recovery especially since she seemed
pretty invested in getting abs
by the end of this so-called challenge
i'm getting the sense that she loves her
oatmeal
and that's great because oatmeal is
packed with fiber and slow burning carbs
so i would never want to remove a meal
like that
what might be more helpful for her
workout recovery however
is to maybe have the oatmeal as a
pre-workout meal
when we actually really need the extra
carbs or if she wants it post-workout
to bump up the protein by throwing in
some protein powder
or powdered peanut butter or egg whites
or tofu etc
again it's all about adding or shifting
things around
not removing them entirely to help
optimize how you
feel and how you perform let's take a
peek at dinner
all right update i just took a shower
and matt just got home and brought us
some pokey so this is what we're gonna
have for dinner okay so i'm not entirely
sure
what is in this so i had to make some
estimations on the nutritional content
but i would expect that we have some
carbs from the rice
protein in the tofu healthy fats from
the avocado
and some fiber rich veggies mixed in i
am a big fan of these poke bowls because
i just find that they're inherently
pretty well balanced and it's always
nice to see an influencer
have the flexibility to eat out
occasionally
and on that note let's get to our big
questions
is this diet balanced well let's start
by addressing
the caloric adequacy of this diet and
trigger warning
i am going to talk numbers in tiffany's
what i in a day to lose six pounds
she says that a lot of people would call
her out for not eating enough since the
commonly suggested caloric
intake is 2 000 calories however tiffany
mentions that those numbers are based on
the average male
and since she's a petite 5-2 woman
they don't apply now i just want to
respectfully clarify that the 1800 to
2000 calorie recommendation
is actually a ballpark figure for women
whereas 2 800 calories is the ballpark
figure often suggested for mend
but that is a moot point of course
because this is all just average
recommendations and it
it doesn't reflect the obvious
differences within men
and women when it comes to their weight
muscle mass activity level
metabolism age etc having said that
when i calculated tiffany's nutrient
needs at a conservative
light activity level using four
different caloric calculation formulas
i got anywhere between 1532 calories
and almost 1700 calories and this was
just for
light activity which is not how i would
necessarily characterize those chloe
ting workouts which
look awesome by the way my estimations
for chloe's intake on day one
was lower than what she estimated and
clocked in at
1330 calories and on days she was doing
the chloe ting challenge where obviously
her nutritional needs
should be even greater she was only
reporting between
977 and 1160 calories
now i can only assume that this is all
she ate on those days because
that is all she showed even though this
video wasn't like an official what i eat
in a day
but to be fair at the time of this
recording the only other what i in a day
video was from over a year ago
and we do try not to go back that far to
give her current diet pattern
a better look so yeah this was pretty
much all i had
as a result of just not eating enough
calories
tiffany is severely under eating on a
lot of the major macro and
micronutrients
her day one macronutrient distribution
had her protein at
seven percent of her daily calories
which in all honesty
in all of the what i in the days i've
done even the really high carb ones
i don't think i've ever seen it get that
low
like ever so for those of you who think
i'm
obsessed with protein there's a pretty
obvious reason to bring it up
in this case she's also only getting
between a quarter and half of her fiber
needs for the day
which i think could be easily remedied
by including more vegetables
fruit and whole grains throughout her
day and honestly
also just more food her intake of
heart-healthy monounsaturated and
polyunsaturated fats like omega-3s
is also lacking and since i didn't hear
anything about a supplement regime i am
also concerned about
calcium vitamin d potassium vitamin c
and iron and this isn't necessarily
because her diet is
bad or inherently unhealthy it's just
because there isn't
enough food provide her with what her
body needs to thrive
i were to give tiffany any advice here
on how to optimize her diet
i would suggest quitting the
intermittent fasting
this lack of fuel in the morning may be
suppressing tiffany's hunger cues
and just making it too hard to fit in
enough meals and enough snacks in her
day
to meet her nutrient needs and also
let's switch things up
oatmeal is a fantastic breakfast and one
of my personal favorite meals
but variety is the spice of life and we
want to aim to get a variety of
nutrients over the course of a few days
or the course of a week to ensure our
body gets the nutrition that it needs
so maybe experiment with some yogurt
parfaits or toast frittatas
tofu scrambles or hashes to get some
more nutrients in that first
meal of the day hey y'all i'm just
multitasking here and a little update
from me
but since filming this review tiffany
posted a new
wedding a day video entitled what i eat
to gain
weight now i'm not seeing any major
shifts in diet patterns in this video
when compared with
everything else i've reviewed but we are
seeing a little bit of a mentality shift
so
tiffany discusses that she's trying to
gain a bit of weight and effort to
grow a bigger booty she also says this
is
a bit of a shift for her because she's
used to eating intuitively
but she's been focusing on calorie dense
foods like protein bars
she's now also focusing on strength
training
and has cut back on her hit and cardio
workouts so it sounds like she's making
some
good changes based on her goals but
since she's
only really had two modest sized meals
it does look like she's still kind of
intermittent fasting
and ultimately just not getting that
many calories in
so again my previous recommendation to
maybe try eating an extra meal
earlier on in the day still holds true
to tiffany's new goals
okay back to pregnant abby now are there
any problematic assumptions made by this
channel
so the truth is there isn't a ton of
content on tiffany's channel
regarding weight loss and diet so in
general it doesn't seem like spreading
misinformation about nutrition is her mo
but i would say that i was a bit
confused by the conflicting messages
in her wedding day about unintentionally
losing six pounds going vegetarian
and then giving explicit diet tips like
chewing a licorice nib
23 times yes we want to be mindful when
we eat and eating slowly
absolutely can help with that and this
might just be
the way tiffany naturally eats and
that's fine
if it works for her it works for me but
i just have to bring this
up because excessively chewing food and
cutting it up into teeny tiny pieces is
a common recommendation on
disordered eating how-to websites and
forums
then at the end of her chloe ting
challenge video she revealed her before
and after weight and trigger warning
folks i'm going to talk numbers
she states that she had lost 2.2 pounds
now that may seem significant
considering that it's
2.3 percent of her total body weight but
2.2 pounds
could also be completely incidental
depending on differences in water
sodium bathroom habits hormones and
where she is in her cycle
sleep etc so i just want to flag that
two weeks of an ab workout even a really
awesome one like chloe's
is unlikely to make any kind of
significant
permanent shifts in people's weight we
also have to consider that based on what
i saw tiffany eat that week
she was likely in a pretty significant
caloric deficit
and that alone may encourage some weight
loss me again
with another update here with baby o um
i just wanted to say that i'm really
happy to hear that she's making some
changes in light of her goal
to gain weight in some of her more
recent videos
but of course there are still a few
other tweaks that i would recommend
like for example adjusting her eating
schedule to have more consistent
meals and snacks throughout the day and
that of course would help her to get in
the calories that she really needs to
meet those goals
so what can we take away that we like
about tiffany's channel
well i have to say tiffany's incredible
energy for one
can somebody bottle that and ship it to
canada for me after this baby comes
thank you very much um but yeah honestly
i think she's super cute and a total
pleasure to watch
i also think that her meals even though
they are few and far between
are pretty accessible and realistic for
most people
like i appreciate the idea of boosting
the nutrition of a packet of
instant oatmeal with adding in some
natural peanut butter
and some fruit and also making a simple
meal out of a prepared veggie burger
some corn on the cob and some grilled
veg that is my style folks and even
though we can all agree that
candy isn't the most healthy meal or
snack
i can also appreciate that she isn't
restrictive of things that she truly
enjoys
in conclusion my sense with tiffany is
that she may not be
intentionally trying to restrict
calories with
pretty aggressive intermittent fasting
she may just not be giving her body
enough opportunities to actually
communicate hunger
and as a result she's just constantly
under eating this can definitely feel
like intuitive eating
but it also may just take some more
experimentation to see
how she operates if she does eat a
little bit earlier on and therefore
gives herself an opportunity
to tune into those cues if there's an
intention to restrict calories
or lose weight there is a pretty good
chance that this is not an
intuitive way to eat as for her weight
loss obviously there's no way for me
or anyone to know what tiffany's true
setpoint weight
is the caloric intake she's currently
operating at
may be appropriate for her i mean it's
totally impossible for me to judge
but based on some of the recommendations
she has made to her followers on how she
lost six pounds
the fact that every calculation i did
pegged her at needing
significantly more fuel and that she has
major gaps in her macronutrient and
micronutrient intakes
i do see signs that this is not the
weight at which her body would thrive
and that losing those precious six
pounds was maybe not ideal
it might have given her a six pack but
folks please note
that most healthy women are just not
meant to have a six-pack
period and on that note that is all that
i have for you guys today
if you like this video please be sure to
give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below with who you'd
like to see me review next
subscribe to the channel and i will see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye
you